[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if the ending
of Hobson show laughter you scratching
your head then fear not because we might
finally have some answers on one of the
film's biggest mysteries throughout this
video I'll be breaking down who I
believe the mysterious voice behind a
Theon is as well as giving all the
evidence to support this there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the film yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into who the voice behind
etienne is okay so throughout Hobson
sure we learn of a mysterious
organization named Etienne that are
pretty much a huge thorn in the side for
our heroes Etienne are the group behind
brixton law the black Superman played by
Idris Elba and it's clear that this
large shadowy conglomerate have control
over a vast network of spies and
assassins Etienne have a mysterious
leader that pulls all of the strings in
the film and at the end after killing
Brixton he announces that Hobbs and sure
are now on his radar
and this teases the two sides going
head-to-head down the line but who
exactly could this be
well inspired by Hobson Shaw I decided
to do a little digging and after looking
up who voices the character on IMDB I
noticed the name champ nightingale now
if you've never heard of him don't worry
because I hadn't either and this is
definitely no a Leicester or is it well
a quick google search of the name brings
up a review that was written on Amazon
for a brand of gin left by none other
than champ nightingale this may seem
like a weird thing to bring up in a
video like this
however the gin company is actually
owned by none other than Ryan Reynolds
who admitted to leaving the review and
trolling his own brand so we have
confirmation that in the past Ryan
Reynolds has used the name champ
nightingale Reynolds of course features
massively in the
and after we watching it with this
knowledge in mind I can definitely hear
aspects of his voice in the distorted
transmissions that we hear one thing we
learn about the voice is that he knows
who Hobbs is and he asks if he remembers
him which is very similar to how agent
Locke played by Reynolds introduces
himself in the first half hour of the
film in addition to this in the movies
post credit scene we learned that Locke
is a stone-cold killer and whilst he's
very jokey in his entire demeanor he's
more than capable of killing countless
people Locke also seems to want nothing
more than to recruit Hobbes again and
this lines up with the voices desire to
meet up with the character down the line
which is how he taunts him in the film's
final few scenes to me this is all way
too much of a coincidence and a
definitely thing that everything lines
up just enough to make it so that
Reynolds could easily be playing the big
bad in a future film after all you don't
really cast an actor have a statue for a
side character I can definitely see him
going head to head with Hobbes and Shaw
in the future obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this theory and if you
agree with me or not make sure you leave
them in the comment section below and if
you enjoy this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of the film which you'll be
linked at the end in it I'll go over all
of the aspects of the movie so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
talk to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then you can follow me
on twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this I also just
want to let you know that we're
currently giving away a free copy of
Avengers endgame on blu-ray to one lucky
winner and all you have to do is like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on Hobson's sure in the comment section
below
the winner will be chosen at random on
August the 10th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from then whoever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hits
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]